cette habitude du cinéma Nawal a été
piqué par des punaises de lit en pleine
séance plusieurs cinémas en
Île-de-France seraient infestés ça s'est
passé le 17 août alors que Nawal allait
voir la voie royale au cinéma UGC Bercy
à Paris pendant la séance la femme de 53
ans a ressenti une désagréable sensation
de piqûre sur le moment je n'ai pas
pensé à des punaises de Lille le siège
que j'avais était très abîmé je me suis
dit que c'était peut-être de simples
puces mais en sortant elle a constaté
que son dos et ses bras étaient couvert
depuis cure en rentrant chez elle Nawal
a immédiatement mis ses vêtements à la
machine à laver mais à oublier de
nettoyer son sac résultat les punaises
de lit ont pu s'y cacher avant
d'investir tout son logement pendant les
jours qui suivaient je me grattais
jusqu'au son je ne dormais pas la nuit
cela faisait plusieurs jours que des
dizaines de spectateurs témoignaient de
leur calvaire sur les réseaux sociaux si
cinéma franciliens ont été signalés le
MK2 de Beaubourg le MK2 Bibliothèque le
cinéma UGC de Châtelet-les-Halles l'UGC
de Noisy-le-Grand l'UGC de Bercy ou
encore le pâté Alésia voici ce qui a
répondu le groupe MK2 les punaises de
lit ne sont pas un problème dans nos
salles c'est un problème parisien nos
actions préventives sont toujours en
place tout au long de l'année et en
continu pareil chez le groupe UGC qui a
ajouté que les punaises de lit ne
transmettent aucune maladie cependant
les spectateurs piquets ne pourront
prétendre à aucun dédommagement
puisqu'il est très complexe d'identifier
l'origine d'une piqûre de punaise de lit
les traitements contre les punaises
coûtent généralement cher Nawal elle a
fait appel à un expert pour les éliminer
son devis a été estimé à 450 euros
parfois les prix peuvent grimper
jusqu'au milliers d'euros
[Musique]